our universe was born billions of years
ago and since that time it's given birth
to millions of galaxies our solar system
and who knows what
else our universe has been evolving for
13.8 billion years but how exactly did
we get here well strap in because today
we're going back in time to explore the
history of the universe in 10 minutes
in the
beginning there was nothing then
suddenly the Big Bang happened and
created our
universe yeah okay maybe it's a little
more complicated than that how this
Cosmic event began is largely a mystery
but once it got started it never stopped
within milliseconds particles like
quarks and photons are formed they're
just just some of the building blocks
that make up the world you know today a
couple of minutes later more elements
were born protons and neutrons combined
to create elements like helium and dyum
and for the next 400 million years the
universe will continue to rapidly
[Music]
expand after hundreds of millions of
years of chaos and Rapid expansion
things slow down a bit
this will begin the formation of the
first structures of our universe think
of these structures as the ingredients
that make up our Stars galaxies and even
planets like Earth next we see the
formation of primordial gas clouds made
up of helium and hydrogen two of the
elements that were created earlier these
gas clouds have been pulled together
over millions of years through the force
of gravity once they came together over
millions of more years they slowly got
denser and
denser but let's speed this
[Music]
up as our gas clouds are getting closer
and denser they're also getting hotter
once the center of one of these clouds
reaches 10 million de Kelvin it'll
suddenly ignite creating a process known
as nuclear fusion the hydrogen atoms
will combine to form helium releasing an
incredible amount of energy
suddenly the first star in our universe
is
born but this isn't the only one Within
These cosmic clouds billions of stars
are now being created and these aren't
just shiny balls of light they're going
to play an integral part in shaping our
universe and not all these stars are
identical as they're born they'll form
into different shapes and sizes some
will be massive blue giants While others
will be smaller red
dwarfs and it's not just their size
that's different stars have different
LIF spans too some live for tens of
millions of years While others live for
trillions and as we've been observing
these Stars something fascinating has
been happening these Stars don't like to
chill in Space by themselves they want
to group together and it just so happens
that when these Stars along with other
particles like gas dark matter and dust
grouped together due to gravitational
forces they formed
galaxies yeah galaxies like the Milky
Way and Andromeda were formed in this
way but that won't be for a couple more
billion
years over hundreds of millions of years
the universe continued to expand more
galaxies formed and they began to evolve
in fascinating ways
in a common theme we've been seeing
throughout our travels the galaxies
started to gravitate toward each other
as these galaxies begin to pull together
they create Galaxy clusters these are
the largest gravitational structures we
know of at this time we're also seeing
some of the stars that formed near the
beginning of the universe starting to
die out they're exploding into
supernovas but don't be sad that they're
dying these supernovas are necessary
sacrifice to provide the universe with
essential elements that will later
create planets and
life speaking of essential elements I
should also mention Dark
Matter this is a mysterious substance
that doesn't emit or absorb any light
and plays a pivotal role in the tapestry
of the
universe even though we can't see dark
matter we know that it has a strong pole
that has helped shape everything up
until now dark matter is like a hidden
framework that's helped form our galaxy
clusters and other elements of the
[Music]
universe okay now is when things get a
little more familiar after several
smaller galaxies come together the Milky
Way begins to
form our sister Galaxy the Andromeda
galaxy is also created during this time
and and in other similar galaxies solar
systems are starting to be created
enormous clouds of gas and dust collapse
under their own gravity bonding together
and creating early planets and solar
systems and it only gets more
interesting from
here okay we've been away for a couple
billion years and during that time the
universe has continued to expand more
solar systems and galaxies are formed
and way more stars have been created
well speaking of stars arguably the most
important star in all of space was born
our
son after our son is born extra gas and
dust surround it over time these
particles Clump together eventually
growing larger and larger this process
is called planetesimals the beginning of
the planet swe know today in our solar
system over time these planetesimals
grow larger and larger through countless
collisions and gravitational attractions
one of these protoplanets that's
emerging is Earth its growth is marked
by a pivotal event a Mars sized body
known as Thea crashes into our
planetesimal which creates what we now
call Earth and our moon similar
collisions of celestial bodies create
the other rocky planets we know today
Mercury Venus and
Mars over in the cooler regions of space
further away from the Sun gas giants
like Jupiter and Saturn are forming but
checking back in on our rocky planets
they look significantly different than
they do in the present day they're a lot
smoother than I remember well just wait
a couple more million years for what's
known as the late heavy bombard M to
occur this Cosmic event saw massive
asteroids hit these rocky planets it
played a huge role in how they're shaped
today okay after billions and billions
of years we finally start to see life
appear in our
universe but don't get too excited these
are simple single- celled organisms
known as
procaryotes they lack many of the
essential features for life today but
are still an important part of our
Evolution you currently have trillions
of them living on your body not long
after this oxygen begins to appear on
Earth and so do multicell organisms
earth's climate is beginning to take
shape and we see the introduction of the
ozone layer which protects life from
harmful radiation from
space okay another couple billion years
have passed and a lot has happened the
organisms that were microscopic have
evolved to become creatures with
vertebrae this is a significant
Milestone and a precursor to all other
vertebrae life on Earth including
you and even more change happens during
this time plants are evolving and
continents are
moving this is the age of reptiles in
Pangia but it also had its
shortcomings a mass extinction event
occurs wiping out a vast majority of the
species that have been so patiently
evolving this sets the stage for
dinosaurs and mammals to emerge and as
this era comes to a close Pangia begins
to fragment laying the groundwork for
our modern
continents and now we're here in the
hundreds of millions of years that have
passed humans have arrived and evolved
modern civilization was born and now
we're looking to move forward again who
knows what's next space travel climate
change future
technology I guess we'll find out when
we travel 1 billion years into the
future but that sounds like a story for
another what if